sam henches will be our northeast ohio
four dealers starting pitcher tonight
sam is making his 12th start a record of
one and four
uh he pitched very well in his last
start against the angels he went four
innings three hits one run he walked one
and struck out two so never faced the
texas rangers before he will get a good
look at it and they have 25 hits in the
first two games of this series isaiah
kiner falefa leading it off after he
batted second of the first two games of
the series
and a routine fly ball to center for
route number one the d-8s tonight
right-handed hitting andy
ibanez
ground ball to third jose ramirez swung
and roll to third two down and that will
bring up adolesce garcia
and a jam shot hit the side of the mound
and rosario with a spin and a perfect
throw to get him how about that a six
pitch inning jordan lyles lyles coming
off a gem at fenway last saturday gave
up just one run in seven innings the
lead off man and center fielder miles
strong
there's a ball driven to deep right
field back is garcia he's out of room
it's out of here miles straw with the
lead off homer his fourth home run of
the season and it's one nothing
cleveland watch him shoot it the other
way this is just a fastball but it's up
a little bit but he stayed on it it goes
down the line and gets out of here and
that's the 32nd home run allowed by
lyles and you know what he get that's a
24th solo shot eight two runners and
that's it now foreign jose ramirez at
first with one out and the count is full
there's a line drive pace hit left field
that'll get ramirez home and big fraud
male's gonna go for two it's misplayed
by peters who tried to backhand it and
the indians lead is now two or nothing
rod meal hit it hard there's the
breaking ball he gets in the strike zone
but the stolen base pays off for ramirez
they're able to add on a big two out hit
by reyes and that's what you want to see
him doing get a couple of base knocks
with runners in scoring positions
something that'll get him going where's
bradley zimmernell one out two one
offering is hit hard deep right field
look out down the line and it is a home
run
bradley zimmer has hit some absolutely
mammoth home runs in the last month the
only question on that one is would it
stay fair
and once it got past the pole then the
question was how far will that baby go
second home run of the inning and a four
run first for cleveland i can't wait to
take another look at this one
boy he got a high heater out over the
plate and look at lyles he knew that
it's not coming back but it's not like
he swung
from his heels
boy yeah i mean you see the strength
that's in the
second deck look at that's old
brockville
center field miles strong racing in has
to dive what a catch
incredible play
this guy is a gold glover in the making
that was dynamite it looked like it was
going to drop for sure
and miles on the dead sprint
diving with the ball out in front of him
just stole a blue pit away that's a
dandy you take away single yeah good
effort nice catch and it brings up jose
trevino 0-1 here's a bouncer third base
and that one
past ramirez trevino is aboard peters
chugging into third they'll wave him to
the plate and no relay throw even
offered trevino drives in the rangers
first run of the night with a double to
left field and it's four to one and boy
wouldn't that be big if solac could
figure out a way to get him in here in
the second
this one hit sharply not into right
field that's a base hit trevino he's
around third the throw will not come
through to the plate and solace drives
in another run rangers get two back
quickly here in the second right here is
low there's still life in this inning
off the end of the bat and ramirez boots
it
that will get two runs to the plate low
trying for second and he is out at
second base both runs scored prior to
the out at second that's the good news
the bad news is the inning is over
andres jimenez struck out his first time
up
hit hard and fair over the bag at first
down the right field line indians take
the lead jett johnson scores hedges into
third he'll be stopped there it's an rbi
double by andreas jimenez and a 5-4
indians lead ahmed rosario chance to
knock in a pair with a base hit here
left field
peters going back makes the catch
tagging and coming home to score his
hedges tagging and getting the third as
ximena's two runs in six for cleveland
and now two down on the inning here is
the 3-2
and a liner base hit and a two-out rbi
knock for jose ramirez makes it a
three-run fourth 7-4 cleveland two outs
jose ramirez out at second base
payoff pitch coming to fran mill reyes
it gets in for a base hit jose speeding
around third he will score frontman will
take it it's an rbi knock here in the
fourth four in the first four in the
fourth 8-4 cleveland
good night jordan lyles bottom of the
fifth inning owen miller will lead it
off
and the two-strike pitch is hit high in
the air
deep left field back is peters he's out
of room that's out of here
on to the home run porch for owen miller
miller parks one to extend the indians
lead to nine to four solac righty
against righty
hit hard out to right field that's
carrying pretty well and it's gone solac
with a line drive home run and for nick
his 10th home run of the year this guy
dj peters
three run homer here on tuesday shoots
this one out to right field headed down
the line and that one is gone
peters with his second home run of the
series like that it is a 9-6 ball game
one out and the indians now could still
add on and get to that fourth run
it's a smash off the glove of patter
falefa in the left field ramirez scores
big man's going for third and he's out
two down but the indians are up now ten
to six the rangers down to their last
out two down in the night through the
indians up 10-6
struck him out to end the game
book it emanuel
strikes out a pair and the indians go
back over the 500 mark for the first
time since august 2nd when they were 52
and 51.
10-6 is the final
you